there was a time when we felt like we
had to justify all this a nerdy [ __ ] to
the outside world a time when we had to
tell people that the accelerated growth
of gaming was worth paying attention to
lizard even paid mr. t to plead our case
I'm mr. t and I'm a knight more what's
your game
World of Warcraft we were reaching
outside of our little gaming ecosystem
to show people that this stuff was worth
taking seriously that geeks weren't just
basement-dwelling weirdos to get people
to just play games and join a growing
culture and by now we all know how the
rest of the story goes real
professionals are being paid millions to
play to entertain and to build this
industry into something that rivals
other forms of media and now we don't
even have to reach outside because our
celebrities are pushing the product
better than anyone all you have to do is
type twitch.tv
into your browser twitch streamers are
our commercials if you're a developer
looking to generate buzz about your new
game look no further than ninja shroud
or doctor disrespect these guys sell
games in our worlds there are Hollywood
celebrities while the eSports stars are
the [ __ ] we don't have to look very
far into the past to find concrete
examples of what I'm talking about on
August 21st
Samsung collaborated with ninja to
create hype around their newest phone
Samsung Galaxy Note 9 beautiful oh this
is good this is clean it's not Samsung's
first foray into eSports or gaming but
another example of the kinds of stars
companies are looking to to sell their
products in 2018 ninja and the high P
generates is proof that streamers can be
a great marketing weapon just look at
what happens when he decides to stream a
new game a few months back when the
fortnight servers were down ninja in
Tim's attack man gave a new battle
royale game a try
Rama Royale
got 100% win ratio baby we to say this
fateful stream was huge for Rome Royale
would be a massive understatement
during June 2018 wouldn't it first team
the game and then subsequently played it
a few more times
royale jumped from an average of 21 of
viewers in May more than 25,000 average
viewers every day and then in July when
Tim and ninjas interest in shooting
chicken has dwindled so too did people's
interest in watching the game which
dropped to just over 6,300 average
viewers the same impact was also felt by
surging first-person shooter Rainbow six
siege after shroud was banned from
playing player and owns battlegrounds
during July 2018 when shroud wasn't able
to play pub G on stream
he took up siege what are these guys
doing these guys doing what are they
doing during that month the game saw its
highest average concurrent viewership
since its release with more than 17
thousand 600 viewers a jump of 5,000
average viewers over the previous month
now of course siege was already a big
name and a game that was on an upward
trend but it's hard to overstate exactly
how much it means when someone is loved
as shroud is playing your game on stream
well we've noticed in the past two years
is
video of demons and YouTube are
extremely extremely strong in terms of
viewership rapper always and constantly
within the top five most watched games
on YouTube but twitch has always been a
little less than this you know like
really disappointing to be honest I
think they are like some features
watching and doing feature that we need
to do on our side but also having people
like shroud and others that are almost
democratizing the game too much more I
would this guy is gonna play a big role
in in how hopefully she becomes to there
but in the not watch titles on on life
as well and it would be softer
recognizes the value those influencers
bring they've created a program to
reward a long time streamers with
special unique in-game cosmetic items
charms that offer incentives for viewers
to sub to those channels those are
people that have been with us relief
from the very beginning the other one
that gave us feedback that they're not
the only one that have stick with us
through operation health and one
matchmaking was really crap and honestly
like really hats off to those guys
because they've been through the moments
when the game was really not in a good
place and that part of why now other
people jump in and there's a large
player base this has been the case with
other games like pub G Bubo has rewarded
players who have stuck with the game for
a long time like shroud and doctor
disrespect with personalized in-game
cosmetics to help build their brand
alongside the game now obviously the
relationships between these streamers
and these smaller games aren't always as
organic as ninja finding a new battle
royale and enchanting his viewers or
shroud styling on people and yet another
competitive FPS this was specifically
prominent with sea of thieves which
averaged roughly 20,000 viewers at a
time during January and March of 2018
while streamers like shroud and summit
1g we're playing the game since that
time streaming numbers have dwindled to
between one and two thousand over the
last few months it's pretty simple if
you want your game to be popular at
least on Twitch these personalities are
gonna have to do this weird public
vetting for you because a lot of gamers
want to play what the big streamers are
playing just like celebrities and
fashion or athletes and footwear
they decide what's cool now there is a
flip side to this conversation from a
streaming standpoint playing games that
are outside of your brand or
outside of the mainstream can be a death
knell for your viewership numbers a lot
of the time the biggest streamers are
known for the games they play
and aside from summit and shroud playing
games outside of that can hurt your
viewership and revenue this creates this
push and pull in a streaming world where
publishers are looking to these top
streamers to market their game but the
streamers have to find a way to stay on
top while doing so take shroud and
Rainbow six for example during July he
may have spiked sieges viewership and
shown a lot of people just how cool the
game is but his personal average
viewership dropped by about 6,000 at the
same time throughout the previous three
months he hovered around 40k
well in July he averaged just over 33 K
so despite his ability to carrier most
six and he the popularity pub G holds
that was carrying shroud disappeared and
honestly shroud is probably less
affected by this
after all he's known for streaming
multiple games someone like ninja whose
popularity has been built around
fortnight at least recently has been met
with stark reactions to his decision to
branch out his average viewership when
playing Grum royale over fortnight tips
for more than 108,000 - roughly 63
thousand that's more than 40,000 people
tuning out at least in part due to a
game change yours can be fickle man you
know what I think I'm on a roll solo on
this one if you don't mind I appreciate
it
what the hell is this since twitches and
livestreams explosion there's been a lot
of conversation about exactly how far it
can go as this generation of stream
viewers become adults can twitch eclipse
television if that's the case then these
heroes we've chosen to stand atop twitch
become even more important to how the
people on the outside and non-endemic
sponsors of you gaming we now know that
streamers can bring more eyes to new
games the real question is how those
games and the larger gaming community
can capitalize on games like realm
royale sea of thieves Gwent and shadow
births have all shown peaks on Twitch
when the biggest streamer has shown
interest but where are they now
maybe we're learning that this world
isn't just about the games it's about
the people playing them
oh my god he got nothing
these guys are nothing in the game I'm
the best thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]